les obsèques de ronald reagan
retransmise en direct sur les grandes
chaînes américaines g funérailles
nationales à washington qu elles ont
assisté les grands de ce monde tous les
acteurs des années qui ont marqué la fin
de la guerre froide
c'est george bush et margaret thatcher
qui ont prononcé l'éloge funèbre nouveau
raté au procès d'outreau l'une des
experts est considéré comme partial
l'audience a été suspendue aujourd'hui
pour entendre une nouvelle fois la
parole des enfants
la fin de la campagne pour les
européennes les derniers meetings avec
un objectif comme à tout va que les
électeurs d'aller voter au parti
socialiste françois hollande appelle à
sanctionner le gouvernement
à l'ump on encourage au vote utile
ventures est entré dans la légende
apôtre de la seule musique artiste
surdoué cet état hier à l'âge de 73 ans
sa musique lui survivra à travers les
modes et les époques
le coup d'envoi de l'euro 2004 demain au
portugal les bleus n'entreront sur la
pelouse que dimanche ce que l'on sait
c'est qu'ils sont au mieux de leur forme
ce que l'on ignore c'est si marcel
desailly le capitaine sera dans l'équipe
qui affrontera l'angleterre
madame monsieur bonsoir après six jours
de deuil la mairie cran aujourd'hui un
dernier hommage à ronald reagan
lors des funérailles nationales dans la
cathédrale de washington les dirigeants
du monde entier ont assisté à cette
cérémonie religieuse qui rappelle dans
l'émotion et la solennité
les obsèques de kennedy c'est george
bush qui a prononcé l'éloge funèbre du
40ème président des états unis et les
prières des américains ont accompagné la
douleur de nancy comme l'avait souhaité
lui-même ronald reagan
dans la lettre qu'il avait adressée au
peuple américain avant de quitter la
scène politique 25 juillet
une salve d'honneur devant le capitole
et le ciel répond en écho par un crachin
grille l'un de ces reagan accroche sa
tristesse au grade d'officier
l'homme dont elle attend la dépouille a
partagé sa vie 52 années la bannière aux
étoiles en las le cercueil du 40ème
président des états unis l'amérique
n'avait pas organisé de telles
funérailles depuis plus de 30 ans dans
la cathédrale nationale de washington
sont rassemblés les puissants de ce
monde
george bush tony blair 25 chefs d'état
et de gouvernement même le président
afghan est venu absence remarquée de
jacques chirac
les anciens sont là aussi mikhaïl
gorbatchev à kerrigan avait demandé
d'abattre le mur de berlin et margaret
thatcher la dame de fer
une amie qui dans un hommage enregistré
affirme que le monde a perdu un grand
libérateur
l'homme qui a gagné la guerre froide
dans son discours george deubeuliou
bouche décrit la vie de ronald reagan
comme une grande histoire américaine et
il salue sa détermination pour lui dit
il l'amérique n'était pas seulement un
endroit dans le monde
elle était l'espoir du bush père prend
aussi la parole et en soulignant
l'humour de reggane réussit à arracher
un rire à nantes 6 et toute l'assemblée
ce soir
ronald reagan survolera une dernière
fois l'amérique à bord d'air force one
l'avion présidentiel
pour rejoindre la californie où il sera
enterrée dans l'intimité familiale
témoignage de la ferveur et de l'émotion
nationale des dizaines de milliers de
personnes se sont inclinés devant la
dépouille mortelle de l'ancien président
au capitole durant toute la semaine
tout comme sur le parcours vers la
cathédrale ils ont salué une dernière
fois ronald reagan sur place alain de
chalvron quelques mots une caresse et un
dernier baiser
nancy reagan n'a pas fini d'émouvoir
l'amérique
des milliers de personnes s'étaient
encore donné rendez vous le long du
parcours du cortège funèbre du capitole
à la cathédrale
je suis simplement venu lui dire adieu
il a changé le monde est bien peu de
gens peuvent dire cela je crois que
c'est pour cette raison qu'on est si
nombreux ici
certains ont fait la queue une bonne
partie de la nuit au capitole la
dernière nul 5000 personnes par heure se
sont ainsi inclinés un instant devant le
catafalque un instant seulement car il
faut bien que tout le monde puisse
passer puisque ses cuites heures
d'attentes à côté des huit ans nous a
donné rien à décourager les admirateurs
du défunt président ni une température
caniculaire ni la foulée mesures de
sécurité lors de la procession
solennelle dans les rues de washington
mercredi
ni le fin crachin d'aujourd'hui rien
n'aura démenti jusqu'au dernier moment
l'incroyable rega nos manies qui s'est
emparée des états unis en enterrant
ainsi spectaculairement ronald regan
l'amérique en terre aussi un souvenir le
souvenir d'une époque où le pays était
en guerre avec personne et où le
terrorisme n'avait pas atteint par
l'amérique
la france était donc représenté par
valéry giscard d'estaing le ministre des
affaires étrangères michel barnier ses
funérailles nationales à washington
jacques chirac entre à paris pour
accueillir une vice premier ministre
chinois au dernier jour de sa visite en
france on retiendra la vente de 20
airbus in d'excellence des relations
commerciales entre paris et pékin
dans l'actualité de ce vendredi en
france ce nouveau coup de théâtre au
procès d'outreau l'audience a été
suspendue et la parole des experts à
nouveau mise en question
l'une d'entre eux experts mais aussi
présidente d'une association d'aidé aux
victimes d'agressions sexuelles est
soupçonné de partialité agnès cartes et
marie christine gryson est l'un des
experts psychologues qui ont examiné les
victimes du procès d'outreau 17 total 17
enfants crédible at elle conclu des
conclusions qui ont d'ailleurs pesé très
lourd dans l'acte d'accusation
or ce matin les expertises de marie
christine gryson ont été invalidés par
la cour d'assises
motif l'experte est trop proche des
parties civiles elle préside en effet
une association d'aidé aux victimes
d'agressions sexuelles
un mélange des genres inacceptable pour
la défense on cherche à expliquer depuis
des semaines des mois ce qui va pas dans
le procès d'outreau
et lorsque les débats finalement se
terminent pratiquement et on nous sommes
à quelques jours des plaidoiries on
constate que l'expert des enfants n'est
pas partial et n'est pas indépendant
vis-à-vis d'une partie mois jouir c
c'est un scandale supplémentaire et
c'est la démonstration d'un fiasco
judiciaire supplémentaires
conséquence une nouvelle expertise des
enfants vient d'être ordonné et le
président de la cour a suspendu
l'audience jusqu'à lundi après-midi le
temps de désigner un nouveau collège
d'experts repartir en expertise des
années après pour de six petits-enfants
c'est quelque chose qui me paraît
complètement ce réaliste ça me paraît
complètement fou
fou sur réaliste les mots sont à l'image
de ce procès décidément hors norme
pourrait-il être ajourné le temps de
réentendre les victimes à la cour lundi
d'en décider à de niort en fin de
matinée le toit d'une salle des fêtes
s'est soudainement effondré pour des
raisons qui restent à déterminer cinq
personnes ont été blessées dont une
fillette sérieusement touché in blood
and demain il n'y aura pas de mariage à
coulonges la salle des fêtes est en
ruine quand le toit du bâtiment s'est
écroulé ce matin
cinq personnes se trouvaient à
l'intérieur pour préparer la noce à
coulonges c'est le choc
trois des victimes légèrement touché
réussissent à se dégager tout seul les
décombres les deux autres la future
mariée elle même et sa fille sont
secourus par les pompiers
la fillette gravement blessé et évacué
par hélicoptère
c'est effrayant avec l'internet arrivé
on nous a dit qu'un certain nombre de
personnes étaient dessous déjà le nombre
était pas défini et surtout comme vous
pouvez le voir les plafonds et effondré
alors on se sent complètement démunis on
envisage iran 3 fr puisque tout était
recouvert la catastrophe a été évitée de
peu
demain plus d'une centaine de convives
devaient se trouver dans cette salle
l'enquète devra expliquer comment une
construction aussi récente moins de 10
ans a pu s'effondrer ainsi et puis un
hôtel meublé où vivaient des familles
africaines ce bâtiment était ravagé par
un incendie la nuit dernière à saint
maur des fossés
c'est tout le quatrième étage qui a été
touché huit personnes sont blessées
gravement parmi elles un enfant de trois
ans et trois adolescents scènes de
panique avant l'arrivée des pompiers de
nombreux occupants ont été sauvés par le
déploiement des grandes échelles au
tribunal de nanterre se sont retrouvés
aujourd'hui les salariés de l'usiné
stmicroelectronics qui ferme pour se
délocaliser ses salariés ont manifesté
leur détresse hier en tentant d'empêcher
les camions de déménager les machines
ont suivi des incidents avec les forces
de l'ordre
aujourd'hui les politiques ont fait le
déplacement à l'été guillet olivier
besancenot sont venus apporter leur
soutien
nouvel épisode de la longue saga du club
med c'est le groupe accor qui devient
premier actionnaire en s'emparant de
près de 30% du capital
le groupe accor qui prend ainsi la place
de leader mondial des vacances haut de
gamme
guy droit
le club med sa quarantaine de villages
paradisiaques c'est gentil organisateur
toujours heureux mais derrière le rêve
la réalité financière 94 millions
d'euros de pertes en 2003 des résultats
un peu meilleurs pour 2004 ont été
annoncés ce matin marrakech
mais la vraie bonne nouvelle c'est celle
ci le géant hôtelier français accor
prend 30% du capital du club med et va
donner au groupe les moyens de redorer
son image
c'est pour nous très important d'avoir
aujourd'hui avec la nouvelle stratégie
que nous définissons stratégie de montée
en gamme stratégie d'un club med
toujours aussi conviviale mais plus
confortable plus raffiné plus novateurs
d'avoir un actionnaire industriel de
long terme qui fait là un choix très
important du côté d'accor le club med
c'est une marque prestigieuse de plus
dans son giron
un corse et déjà 4000 hôtels dans le
monde de la gamme économique au luxe
accord c'est aussi des restaurants ou
encore des services en devenant
l'actionnaire majoritaire du club med le
groupe français renforce sa position de
poids lourd du tourisme mondial depuis
de plusieurs années nous nous disons que
nous avons une stratégie visant à
satisfaire toutes les clientèles
d'affaires et de loisirs de l'économique
au luxe
sept cadres la queue leu leu rayonnement
l'un expertise de club med nous aideront
considérablement dorénavant été comme
hiver lors de vacances en france il sera
très difficile d'échapper au groupe
accor
le marché de la téléphonie mobile
français s'apprête à accueillir le
premier opérateur virtuel sa
particularité il ne possède pas de
réseau mais offre tous les services d'un
opérateur classique pour les
consommateurs davantage donc de
concurrence dans un marché qui ne se
jouer qu'à 3 jusqu'à présent françois
beaudonnet bernard puceau les joies du
portable concernent déjà 42 millions de
personnes en france
un chiffre qui pourrait grimper à 50
millions sous peu avec l'arrivée
d'opérateurs virtuels
il s'agit d'entreprises sans réseau
propre qui se contentent d'acheter des
minutes de communication en grande
quantité aux opérateurs qui eux ont
construit un réseau elle les revendre
ensuite à leurs clients ce matin
le premier de ces opérateurs virtuels a
vu le jour
debitel société allemande devient donc
le quatrième opérateur de l'hexagone
avec pour cible tous ceux qui n'ont pas
encore de portables ainsi que les
communautés étrangères entre 5 et 7
millions de personnes au sein de ces
communautés qui consacrent l'essentiel
de leur budget téléphonique pour appeler
leurs proches et leur famille dans leur
pays d'origine qui utilise
essentiellement aujourd'hui le fixe le
téléphone fixe et pour lesquels nous
pensons pouvoir réaliser des offres
intéressantes et compétitive pour y
parvenir debitel revendra à prix cassés
des communications et des sms
acheter en gros à sfr nous sommes
convaincus que l'arrivée d'un quatrième
opérateur en 2004 va dynamiser le marché
et que c'est l'intérêt des opérateurs et
des français
cette bataille devrait surtout se jouer
sur le prix des sms jugé trop cher par
beaucoup et pour les associations de
consommateurs qui réclament plus de
concurrence dans la téléphonie mobile
il s'agit seulement d'un premier pas le
problème avec les opérateurs virtuels
qui arrive c'est que ce sont deux tout
petits acteurs donc ça n'aura pas
d'impact significatif sur le marché
après debitel d'autres opérateurs
virtuels pourrait débarquer bref
beaucoup d'animations en perspective
alors que la canicule touche italie et
que la france a connu cette semaine ses
premières fortes chaleurs les maisons de
retraite se prépare à faire face en test
le matériel on installe la climatisation
un dispositif technique aux points mais
qui ne pallie pas le manque de personnel
ceci mais elle mathieu dans le jo ils
ont été commandés cet automne les voici
enfin livré une quinzaine de
ventilateurs prévu pour les chambres des
pensionnaires dans cette maison de
retraite de l'essonne c'est le branle
bas de combat anti canicule en moins
d'un an des volets déroulant on s'était
installé dans une pièce la climatisation
dans l'autre cette pièce nous avons
privilégié pour rafraîchir des bonbonnes
d'eau seront bientôt disponibles à
chaque étage en plus de brasseurs d'air
de remise ateurs et j'en passe de son
côté la préfecture multiplie les
courriers rappelant aux directeurs
d'établissements leurs responsabilités
il faut tout prévoir
au cas où mais s'il n'y a pas de
canicule eh bien nous aurons été
prévenants et nous sont notre source
pour 900 aucun problème
ici l'an dernier on a déploré deux décès
directement lié aux fortes chaleurs il
on sait qu'il faut être d'autant plus
vigilant avec les personnes âgées que
leurs thermostats interne est totalement
déréglé difficile de leur faire boire de
l'eau la grenadine ça passe beaucoup
mieux et c'est souvent un drame si on
essaye de les séparer de leur petite
laine et même par 32 degrés allons je
suis pas dérangé par la chaleur même pas
pas la grosse chaleur
mais le point noir des maisons de
retraite
révélée par la crise l'an dernier n'a
toujours pas été résolu moi je vois que
cette année je suis encore plusieurs
difficultés pour recruter et du
personnel pour les congés d'été les
mêmes du personnel sur des contrats à
durée indéterminée dans dix embauches
règne dans l'établissement les
préfectures suggère que les
établissements rappelle leur personnel
en vacances il devait y avoir une
nouvelle crise
mais comment avec quel budget il reste
encore beaucoup de questions en suspens
à la rochelle par souci de précaution
les quelques 360 patient qui avait subi
une coloscopie ses 360 patiente été
contacté par le centre hospitalier st
louis un appareil dont la procédure de
désinfection n'a pas été scrupuleusement
suivi oblige à de nouveaux examens
sanguins pour assurer les malades et les
médecins c'est le fabricant de
l'appareil qui alerte et l'hôpital il en
martinet philippe vitel entre les mains
de ce médecin un cool ou ce qu il permet
d'examiner les parois intestinales
mais à l'hôpital de la rochelle depuis
un an et demi cet instrument était mal
stérilisée conséquence 360 patients sont
susceptibles d'avoir été exposés à une
infection virale
le problème serait effectivement un
virus puisse être transmis d'un patient
à un autre parce que cet appareil a été
mal désinfectées parce qu'il a été
partiellement les infectés mais je pense
que le risque
demant hiv hépatite b hépatite c les
infections semble peu probable ce risque
peut exister de façon unitaire mais est
très très faible
donc je pense qu'il faut tout à fait
rassuré les patients principe de
précaution oblige les 360 patients
concernés ont été contactés
tous devront se soumettre à un
prélèvement sanguin
la direction de l'hôpital elle évoque
une mauvaise application des protocoles
de désinfection
les choses sont en cours d'analysé pour
en travers de l'enquète interne pour
déterminer fectivement là où a lieu le
dysfonctionnement déjà plus d'une
trentaine de patients a été examiné
aucun cas d'infection n'a été
diagnostiquée 24 ans après les épreuves
de philo les bachelières le week-end
pour souffler mais aussi pour préparer
l'autre épreuve phare les maths lundi
matin à villatte à bord y réussissent
mater trop de stress après l'épreuve de
philo trop de pression à évacuer etienne
candidats au bac es n'avait qu'une envie
aujourd'hui décompresser avant de
reprendre les révisions je sais que si
je reste moi en me disant il faut
absolument que je travaille et qu'est-ce
qui enfin je serai pas par quel bout le
prendre je ne bougerai pour rien alors
que si je viens ici une des tendances et
nice je suis dans les meilleures
conditions pour travailler après lui pas
pu s'infliger du haleine 2 x un quizz
pour tester leurs connaissances en maths
des révisions en forme de juin étienne
laissé des amis ont maintenant tout le
week-end pour préparer le reste des
épreuves et ils ont l'air plutôt sur 2 0
+ 2 mpx mon infinie
on a travaillé tout au long de l'année
alors c'est pas aujourd'hui en deux
jours que de toute façon va tout à
apprendre
j'adore c'est pas vrai c'est vrai qu'on
peut réviser mais c'est pas pour ça
qu'il faut être plus stressé que ça dure
en révisant son compte qu'on connaît
beaucoup de choses en fait
chez les marshals le bac c'est une
affaire de famille etienne est le
premier des trois enfants à le passer
alors depuis un mois ses parents font
tout pour ne pas le déconcentrer danses
et les musiques ont dû entendu
il faut qu'on soit cool en ce moment et
tout ça j'ai entendu cette discussion je
sais qu'ils font d un effort particulier
pour pas me poser cette pression mais
moi je la sens je sais qu'elle existe je
sais que je veux pas les décevoir
évidemment je compte sur lui parce que
parce que ça passagers c'est un passage
on a eu vécu déjà points de passage avec
11 en france celui là il est important
parce que la société veut que le
baccalauréat souhaite une transition
les épreuves reprennent lundi avec
l'histoire géo
puis viendront les maths les langues et
les sciences une dure semaine en
perspective pour les candidats avant les
résultats prévue début juillet la
campagne pour les européennes s'achève
ce soir avant le scrutin à un tour
dimanche les partis politiques et
tiennent leurs derniers meetings avec
l'ambition et la nécessité de convaincre
les électeurs d'aller voter
on commence par le ps françois hollande
entouré de tous les siens et encouragés
par les résultats aux régionales led une
nouvelle fois pour le vote sanction
contre le gouvernement raffarin
alexandre kara basque compte entre
laurent fabius et françois hollande le
ton est à la plaisanterie c'est que chez
les socialistes moral est au plus haut
pour ce dernier meeting de la campagne
pas une tête de liste ne manquait à
l'appel et pour le ps avoir imposé
l'europe sociale comme principal thème
de débat des élections est déjà un
succès je voulais une règle en politique
c'est que ceux qui choisissent les
thèmes et qui les imposent ce sont ceux
là qui gagne l'élection plus d'élections
programmés avant 2007
alors le psg toutes ses forces dans la
bataille l'histoire de s'imposer dans
les trois années d'avant présidentielle
comme un interlocuteur légitime face à
la majorité une majorité accusée d'avoir
tout fait pour étouffer la campagne elle
fait donc le pari de la torpeur estivale
de l'oubli même de l'élection
l'abstention est sa meilleure alliée
les ministres d'ailleurs ont compris
qu'ils ne voulaient pas eux aussi être
touchés par la vague qui monte
on ne les voit pas dans cette campagne
il battait les estrades
il y a plusieurs mois ils se cachent
aujourd'hui je le dis souvent la droite
n'est pas en campagne elle est en fuite
objectif pour le ps être le premier
parti de france au soir du 13 juin
une victoire qui aurait aussi davantage
pour françois hollande de lui permettre
de rentrer dans le club des
présidentiables socialistes et l'ump on
ne ménage pas non plus à peine au palais
des sports à paris alain juppé et jean
pierre raffarin venus en renfort on sait
tribune commune pour lancer un appel au
vote utile éviter le gaspillage des voix
miquel d'armand et barbe à nice quand la
pluie de confettis tombe dans le silence
et que la marseillaise ne part pas au
bon moment il est temps que la campagne
s'arrête dernière réunion publique
d'alain juppé avant son départ de l'ump
première est aussi dernier meeting
électoral pour jean pierre raffarin la
s'éloigne pour être rejugée l'autre
craint d'être sanctionnés alors la
consigne celle enthousiasme dota gens
bien hraparak je ne vous parle d'un
projet avec précisément en bougeant
alain juppé a rappelé la position de
l'ump pour un référendum sur la
constitution européenne
il a également parlé du besoin d'une
politique industrielle
un peu à la manière de nicolas sarkozy
est là applaudissements garantis ans il
faut défendre alstom il faut défendre
sanofi aventis il faut constituer de
grands groupes industriels européens
jean pierre raffarin persévérant et
surtout candidate pour rester à son
poste comme son collègue belge la
persévérance seville fried martens parce
qu'il ya eu martens 9
on en est qu'à raffarin iii à la veille
de ce deuxième test électoral dans les
coulisses de l'ump au cra le score des
souverainistes et surtout de l'udf dont
la bonne santé fragilisent le parti
chiraquien
quant à jean marie le pen il tenait à
benquet pour son dernier meeting à paris
en compagnie de ses têtes de liste
l'occasion de lancer ces dernières
piques contre l'union européenne la
condamnation de maurice papon à 10 ans
de réclusion pour complicité de crimes
contre l'humanité cette condamnation est
définitivement confirmée la cour de
cassation vient de rejeter le pourvoi de
voris patron ce n'est pas pour rien
qu'on l'avait surnommé le général
charles reste et restera dans la mémoire
collective comme l'une des grandes
légendes du siècle musicien surdoué
aveugle à l'âge de 7 ans raid ça c'était
d'abord une voix des lunettes noires et
une façon si singulière de se balancer
devant son piano il était l'apôtre de la
soul music il s'était ainsi hier à l'âge
de 73 ans mais sa musique sa musique lui
survivra évocation de michel mompontet
qui a personnellement inconnu raid
chance
pouvoir faire marche arrière de ramener
sur terre ne serait ce qu'un instant le
temps d'une chanson et en entendant sa
voix voir défiler sa vie
le voir quitter son lit de mort
notre une dernière fois sa chemise de
fait écouter encore sa voie il regardait
sa vie qui passe lui dont 74 ans durant
les années 30 quand on essaie en géorgie
il ne fallait être ni noir ni pauvre
rester les deux mauvaise pioche
réa six ans quand il ne peut empêcher
son frère de se noyer devant lui il est
trop petit
notre trop lourd les sur irréparable
extinction des juges locaux à 7 en ré
n'est plus qu'un enfant avait bu du
shérif du fonds de l'alabama
il y a des vies qui commence mieux mais
c'est le même homme
cinquante ans plus tard qui est honorée
comme un trésor national par les
présidents des états unis loin de
l'école pour enfants aveugles de
l'alabama loin mais jamais oublier flash
back
sapin
non moi
non
en une chance en 1953 le général charles
révolution de la musique noire
américaine
ces disques pulvérise les records de
vente et avec la régularité d'un
métronome smith il va enchaîner les
titres de légende
et puis cette voix cette voix si
particulier
reach en remplir et l'épée 20 ans avant
les clodettes avec le swing en plus
spectacle après spectacle disque après
disque en échange va inventer une
manière unique d'exprimer de chanter un
jouet de la bouche on appelle ça la soul
music
quarante ans durant une moyenne de 240
concerts par an ça fait huit mille fois
sur scène du premier appareil en 59 au
dernier quand le bonheur de vivre se
déglingue un peu mais que la voie reste
fidèle jusqu'au 1
le temps est écoulé faire marche arrière
est impossible à la fin
le blues gagne toujours
le csars dit
le france 2 lui consacrera une émission
spéciale dimanche prochain à partir de
23h30
aux etats unis ont été dispersées
aujourd'hui lors d'une grande vente aux
enchères à new york et les derniers bien
de katherine hepburn suivant salle les
dernières volontés de l'actrice disparue
il ya un an les admirateurs ou
collectionneurs venus du monde entier
passent quelques la mère katherine
hepburn auto portrait impitoyable
un croquis parmi quelque 700 autres lots
mis en vente et qui résume toute une vie
vie publique vie privée
les livres les carnets intimes les
télégrammes certaines de ses robes et
les fans qui n'avaient vu d'elle que ces
films qui se souviennent de son élégance
exceptionnel rêve d'acquérir un petit
quelque chose de leur idole elle était
une actrice formidable mais c'était
aussi une femme courageuse unique en son
genre et c'est pour cela que je l'admets
femme de caractère à l'écran katherine
hepburn vivait à l'écart des modes dans
ses résidences de new york de los
angeles ou du connectique ses meubles
ses bibelots ses peintures n'ont guère
de valeur en eux mêmes mais elles les
aînés elle était sa propre décoratrice
d'intérieur le style de madame memeburn
c'était sa propre vie elle voulait
s'entourer d'objets qui évoquait quelque
chose pour elle l'amour de sa vie sept
et spencer tracy liaison discrète que
les objets racontent aujourd'hui le
fauteuil dans lequel il aimait se
reposer son visage sculpté par katherine
hepburn qu'elle à garder auprès d'elle
jusqu'à sa mort
la sculpture comme tout ce qui a été
mise en vente aujourd'hui atteint des
prix bien au delà des prévisions des
experts 275 mille dollars dernier prix
plus que jamais katherine hepburn fait
tourner la tête à ses admirateurs du
côté des étoiles la nasa suit
attentivement à l'entrée dans la
banlieue de saturne de la sonde cassini
une mission internationale qui permettra
à l'équipe de la planète pendant quatre
ans nicolas chateauneuf
elle a commencé son voyage il ya sept
ans et depuis la sonde cassini huygens a
parcouru plus de 3 milliards de
kilomètres objectif
saturne et ses légendaires anneaux
saturn joyau du système solaire dès ce
soir cassini frôlé un des nombreux
satellites de la géante gazeuse avant la
délicate mise en orbite prévue le 1er
juillet mais le clou du spectacle est
prévu pour la fin de l'année
cassini larguera alors une petite sonde
dans l'atmosphère de titan une des
trente deux lunes de saturne qui
intrigue particulièrement les astronomes
à une instit en possède la surface
solide inexplorée la plus vaste du
système solaire les scientifiques
pensent que l'atmosphère de titan
ressemble à celle de la terre
quand la vie est apparu le 14 janvier
2005 après 20 jours de plongé dans
l'atmosphère de titan
le parachute de la sonde s'ouvrira enfin
et nous serons alors peut-être à quoi
peut ressembler un océan extraterrestre
l'actualité sportive avec le coup
d'envoi de l'euro 2004 demain au
portugal les bleus entreront sur la
pelouse que dimanche ce que l'on sait
c'est qu'ils sont au mieux de leur forme
ce que l'on ignore ses 6 et marcel
desailly le capitaine sera dans l'équipe
qui affrontera l'angleterre florent
gautreau à des sièges la maison bleue
est bien gardé et pourtant il sait pas
encore quelle sera sa défense contre
l'angleterre ça ne perturbe pas plus que
ça les gamins de santos hierso qui ne
savent même pas que l'habituel capitaine
des français n'est pas sûr de jouer et
de saillies lui fait comme si de rien
n'était il n'a jamais été aussi proche
du banc de touche mais on n'a jamais vu
aussi décontracté à l'entraînement en
fait personne ne sait vraiment s'il sera
titulaire
je crois que si marseille ne joue pas
c'est que quelque part lui en main dans
l'est
parce qu'il peut pas jouer mais je crois
que marcel desailly c'est le capitaine
équipe de france il assez d'expérience
il a jouer des grands matches il a sans
casser sélection les autres français
d'angleterre eux attendre ce premier
match avec impatience sur les 23
sélectionnés neuf évoluent dans le
championnat anglais et connaissent leurs
adversaires par coeur henry et pires
vont retrouver ashley cole leurs
coéquipiers à arsenal mais à deux jours
du match pas question de se laisser
déstabiliser
daschle et a commencé déjà un peu allumé
dans la presse que ça anglaise donc on
va dire c'est toujours gentil il ya
toujours une certaine limite qu'il
allait respecter donc non c'est bien en
tout cas
en tout cas on a hâte d'y être à
dimanche les bleus vont quitter porto
demain matin 11h30 pour lisbonne
aujourd'hui à l'entraînement on a senti
la tension monte d'un cran et avec ou
sans marcel desailly l'équipe de france
est bien décidé à effacer le souvenir de
l'échec du mondial 2002 du côté anglais
la vedette incontestée c'est david
beckham à sa vie privée sans savoir
jouer sa popularité alimentent tous les
fantasmes portrait du joueur de football
le mieux payé au monde
manuel tisser nadine picard dans toutes
les positions
david beckham est une vedette ce matin à
l'entraînement avec l'équipe
d'angleterre 7 et beckham le footballeur
mais hier à la une du journal dans une
pose beaucoup moins avantageuse 7 et
beckham trois des paparazzi des dizaines
de journalistes dès qu'il prend la
parole et ses moindres faits et gestes
affiché en une des tabloïds
david beckham fait vendre du papier ça
ne me fait pas plaisir de me retrouver
en première page dans cette tenue
mais dans un sens je ne suis pas surpris
de tout ce qui se passe et de tout ce
que l'on écrit sur moi car david beckham
est un pro des médias et du business
avec sa femme chanteuse victoria
ils ont fondé un véritable empire
beckham ne fait pas que le bonheur des
supporters et des journaux à scandale
il prête son image à une boisson gazeuse
une huile pour moteurs des produits de
beauté ou des consoles de jeux
tout cela on fait le footballeur le plus
riche du monde plus de 22 millions
d'euros par an soit un salaire mensuel
de 12 millions de fruits cam est le
premier joueur professionnel de football
à avoir institué une marque en même
temps qu'à fine et un plan de carrière
le meilleur argument de vente de beckham
reste son pied droit
le capitaine anglais est d'abord un
joueur d'exception et les français ont
plus à craindre de sa force de frappe de
son pouvoir d'achat
direction le portugal la pays en liesse
avec pour le premier match l'équipe
nationale qui affrontera la grèce la
ferveur des supporteurs encadrés par
d'importantes mesures de sécurité à
porto christelle bertrand ses mérites
sont vendu à la criée
ses couleurs sont celles de l'été sans
jouer la sélection portugaise a déjà
gagné tous les coeurs je suis très
heureux et on va tout faire pour que
notre équipe gagne jamais la fierté
nationale ne s'est rendue si visible
c'est l'entraîneur du portugal qui a
lancé un appel de soutien
les brésiliens et au brésil on accroche
des drapeaux partout
du coup on se met à rêver d'une victoire
qui pourrait propulser le portugal
numéro un d'europe
moi je pense que le portugal va gagner
et il faudrait ton - sar pour apaiser
les mécontents ceux qui trouvent que
l'état a dépensé trop d'euros 600
millions exactement dix stades tout
neufs comme celui de porto et voilà le
budget construction qui explose de 180%
mais l'euro s'est aussi une publicité du
pays pour plusieurs milliards de
téléspectateurs
nous allons montrer au monde deux choses
d'abord que nous sommes capables de bien
organiser un événement si important dans
un temps record et que nous pouvons
recevoir les gens vont avec hospitalité
le bleu est aussi une couleur dominante
les forces de police omniprésente sont
l'art pour dissuader les individus
voudrait gâcher la fête pour la réussite
de l'événement le gouvernement compte
sur l'accueil de la population
le premier ministre a donc envoyé une
lettre à chacun de ses concitoyens où il
rappelle que tous les portugais sont
sélectionnés pour l'euro je vous propose
à présent une balade architecturale sur
la côte basque dans cette station
balnéaire lancée par napoléon iii
biarritz est un véritable musée à ciel
ouvert jean jacques duffau jean mi melle
à biarritz recèle des trésors des
trésors plus ou moins cachés et des
trésors d'architecturé délirante chacun
ce qui va en vie
commençons donc la belle aide par l'une
des maisons les plus symboliques de la
ville
la ville avait déjà fait rêver tous les
yaro parce qu'elle est resté abandonné
pour des pointes de succession pendant
longtemps maintenant est divisée en
appartements
celle ci est encore presque abandonné et
aimé va faire l'objet je pense
une réhabilitation une transformation
bientôt autrefois le château d'ilbarritz
était la propriété d'un excentrique
passionnés de musique le baron de l'épée
cette maison a été construite
principalement pour mettre un ordre qui
après lors des différentes ventes a été
déplacée démonter et qui se trouve au
sacré coeur à paris récemment transformé
en chambres d'hôtes la ville là le
goéland offre trois chambres avec vues
ces petites merveilles qui ont failli
disparaître à cause de la spéculation
immobilière sont désormais classés une
procédure qui concerne plus de 800 villa
et bâtiments on pouvait craindre une
réaction difficile de la part des
propriétaires parce que ça veut dire que
on peut pas remplacer une villa ou un
immeuble de deux étages par un immeuble
de quatre étages ou de ces états
la réaction a été dans l'ensemble
extrêmement positif parce que je crois
qu'il ya une très grande fierté de la
ville par rapport à son patrimoine
le patrimoine d'un ancien village de
pêcheurs transformé par l'impératrice
eugénie en ville princière
princière c'est ce que l'on pourrait
dire de la maison d'edmond rostand elle
n'est pas à biarritz mais à
cambo-les-bains à l'intérieur du pays
basque l'extérieur est très intégrée
dans la nature néo basque et l'intérieur
vous allez le découvrir et totalement
éclectique déborde de de décors de
toutes sortes on a du baroque on a de
l'anglais on a dû chinois
c'est extraordinaire c'est un véritable
décor théâtral ce décor charmant et de
bourse les pays avec l'argent que lui a
rapporté cyrano de bergerac une pièce à
succès la preuve le succès l'argent ça
ne fait pas le bonheur mais cela permet
quand même de réaliser quelques
fantasmes situe à hendaye le château
d'abbadie en est l'illustration parfaite
il avait une fortune colossale qu'il
avait héritée de ses parents
donc travailler
construit entre 1860 et 1870 par viollet
le duc le château d'abbadie mérite lui
aussi une petite visite
une visite qui vous permettra de devenir
copropriétaires puisque si j'en crois
victor hugo la façade d'une maison
appartient aussi à celui qui la regarde
julio iglesias ou le grand retour
imaginer que le crooner latin ne s'était
pas produit en france depuis plus d'un
quart de siècle il commence une tournée
avec une escale au palais des congrès à
paris ce week-end sophie jouvet didier
dalleau rencontrer ça faisait 27 ans
qu'elle attendait leur julio 27 ans
qu'il n'avait pas chanté en france
tant d'années à espérer ce baiser de lui
évidemment il a 27 ans de plus mais le
charme continue à opérer
demandez vous si tous ces relations
voilà
ce soir-là lille le premier concert du
plus international des crooners pour ses
groupies française avait des airs de
premier rendez vous galant
qu'est ce qui vous séduit chez lui
on donne à voir il est beau enfin
quelqu'un qui sait parler aux peur quand
ça nous fait rêver
il voit là le secret d'une telle
longévité à plus de 60 ans l'art de
chauffer une salle est de faire croire à
chacune qu'elles emanuela
quand on sort d'anne à la salle du
théâtre et tout d'un coup tu reçois
cette énergie du public qui te reçois
avec chaleur c'est quand tu dis avance
dans ta vie dans ton change
les singles bouge une façon différente
et sans beaucoup plus sous la peau
c'était ça beaucoup même
250 millions de disques vendus plus
qu'elle dise est toujours le même
sourire de bel hidalgo une longue
tournée française pour appeler que
chantait l'amour est un vrai métier est
célébrée de tendres retrouvailles
je
toujours le même parlé j'ai toujours le
même petit sourire
y at-il au sabre et malhonnêtement
le
ainsi se termine ce journal tout de
suite le poids route valérie maurice
puis la météo présentée par nathalie
rihouet 20h55 qu'un numéro à minuit le
dernier journal leur expliquer demain
matin dans quelques faits catherine
ceylac recevra marie-anne chazel quant à
moi j'en ai plusieurs de vous retrouver
du 13 heures je vous remercie de votre
attention excellente fin de soirée sur
france 2 se fixe sur ces images de paris
port de pêche sur lesquels vous pourrez
visiter une dizaine de navires amarrés
au quai saint bernard dans le cinquième
à rome